Russia steals and not only Ukrainian
Plumbing culture and history it steals
the most valuable thing from Ukraine
ukrainians
if it weren't for Russia the word
deportation would have become archaic
long ago they're stealing people more
than one million and 600 thousands of
ukrainians we are forcibly deported to
Russia they are dispersed across the
territory of this state scattered
throughout remote Russian regions many
of them and their documents taken away
and many of them passed through terrible
Russian filtration camps where they were
abused and intimidated
these are people
but for Russia it's also a resource in
2022 after Russia's full-scale invasion
of Ukraine human rights Watchers
reported mass deportations of ukrainians
from cave police regions
no one asked us what we wanted or how we
wanted it
if I had a choice I would never have
crossed the border with Russia
Russian soldiers came into our basement
in the morning and said that if we
didn't leave we'd be shot
the Russian military is destroying
Ukrainian cities and towns and
preventing ukrainians from fleeing to
the territories under Ukraine's control
[Music]
Additionally the occupiers are mass
deporting ukrainians to Russia calling
this evacuation and referring to those
deportees as refugees
meanwhile the evacuation of civilians
and foreigners continues along the cave
in mariopal directions
with these phrases they try to hide the
fact that deportations are Russia's
deliberate policy which it inherited
from the Soviet Union
a totalitarian regime that during its 69
years of existence carried out nearly
110 rounds of deportations which
forcibly displaced almost 6 million
innocent people
so when Russia says we can repeat it
they are repeating these imperialistic
scenarios
so-called Russian World brings
occupation oppression and genocide to
free countries
foreign
War II the Soviet Union occupied the
Baltic countries twice
both times in order to eliminate
resistance from the local people who
wanted Independence the Soviet regime
carried out Mass deportations
the first deportation took place in the
summer of 1940.
Soviet troops entered the Baltic
countries established controlled
governments and initiated Mass cleansing
or filtration measures as they would say
now people from the Baltic countries
were stigmatized as traitors and were
accused of engaging in so-called
anti-revolutionary activity and
anti-soviet agitation
he said
children cried terribly and ran to their
parents
wives rushed to their husbands but
soldiers pushed everyone away
still doesn't know exactly what the
Soviet authorities accused her parents
of it is likely that the fact that both
of them were teachers and therefore
belonged to the Lithuania Intelligentsia
was enough to raise suspicion from
Lithuania alone in 1940 more than 10
percent of the country's population was
deported to Siberia even the presidents
of Estonia and Latvia were forcibly
displaced and later died in deportation
the genocide and Lithuanian resistance
Research Center in Venus has collected
documents and artifacts from those times
after the arrival of Soviet power in
1940 more than 200 000 lithuanians more
than 10 percent of the population were
deported to Siberia
according to various estimates a total
of 140 000 to 300 000 people were
forcibly deported from the Baltic
countries in their official documents
the Soviet authorities openly used the
term deportation and reported on the
implementation of their operational plan
for the extraction of anti-soviet
contingents
about 50 years later a new generation of
Soviet authorities recognized those very
deportations as unlawful but in 2020
Russia's President Vladimir Putin brings
back the aggressive rhetoric and for
this we will strive for the
demilitarization and natification of
Ukraine in his article marking the 75th
anniversary of victory over Nazi Germany
he called the Soviet occupation of the
Baltic countries a legitimate annexation
[Music]
oh
so strange that South and North Korea
are located on the other side of the
globe but for some reason we live here
it was incomprehensible for me as a
child and this issue was not addressed
in any way only recently
got an explanation that the Koreans were
deported from the Far East and resettled
in Central Asia
at the beginning of the 20th century
many Korean Farmers moved to the Far
East regions of the USSR fleeing from
Japanese Occupation
but in September 1937 the Soviet
authorities suddenly decided that the
ethnicity of these immigrants was
confusing
according to official statements people
could not distinguish Korean people from
Japanese people and in order to prevent
infiltration of Japanese spies the
authorities forcibly displaced 172 000
ethnic Koreans to uninhabited Wasteland
regions of Kazakhstan and Central Asia
when the deportees arrived in Kazakhstan
they were also forced to Forfeit their
Korean names and adopt Russian ones
ethnic Germans in Ukraine also suffered
from the Soviet repressions on the basis
of ethnicity as a reminder the first
settlements of Germans in Ukrainian
territory date back as early as the 11th
century
and in the 18th century there were
several large waves of image from
religious conflicts
at this time Germans in Ukraine were
given land allotments Exempted from
taxes for 10 years and free from the
mandatory military service Forever on
the eve of World War II approximately
half a million Germans lived in Ukraine
and suddenly after Nazi Germany attacked
the Soviet Union in the summer of 1941
they all became enemies of the state
[Music]
Soviet authorities Mass deported Germans
from Ukraine to the north and Far East
of the USSR territory
those people who were registered as
anti-soviet elements were arrested
able-bodied men between the ages of 16
and 60 were sent to labor camps
the German people who had lived in
Ukraine their entire lives were accused
of collective guilt on ethnic grounds
and as a result of repression by the end
of the war there were almost no Germans
remaining in Ukraine
the administrative ban on Germans
returning to Ukraine was lifted no
sooner than in 1972 27 years after the
end of the second World War
it was after the forced removal of
Germans that deportations in the Soviet
Union went to another level
foreign
by paranoid suspicions of the
population's collaboration with the
Enemy the nkvd forcibly resettled about
400 000 chechins in eight days in
February of 1944. they were accused of
mass collaboration with Nazi occupiers
despite the fact that the Invaders only
took control over a small region in the
far Northwest of the Republic
the deported chechens were scattered
throughout the country and placed in the
special settlements which they were not
allowed to leave any further than a
couple of kilometers
they were forced to work on the
collective farms and in factories for a
miniscule salary despite their hard
physical labor
they were not allowed to use their
native language
the Chechen children attended only
Russian primary schools
following their deportation the Chechen
people were labeled as traders of the
motherland
this nation spent 13 years in forced
Exile
in 1957 the Soviet authorities finally
cleared the chechen's reputation and
allowed them to return to their Homeland
foreign
[Music]
the Soviets also initiated cleansing of
the Crimean peninsula of its native
inhabitants
in April 1944 lavrenti Beria the chief
of the nkvd wrote a report to Joseph
Stalin where he accused Crimean tatars
of Mass desertion from the Red Army
shortly after this between the 18th and
21st of May Crimean tatars were forcibly
removed to middle Asia and the Ural
region
yeah
I am from Crimea myself a Crimean Tatar
my parents are also from Crimea but they
were already born in deportation
my father was born in Central Asia I was
also born in Central Asia but my
grandfather my grandmother they were all
born in Crimea
they were falsely accused of mass
treason and collaboration during the
time of German occupation the Soviet
authorities deported even those tatars
who had served in the Red Army and were
officially discharged that is
deportation was one of their instruments
of genocide
according to official figures in 1944
the Soviet regime deported approximately
20 000 tatars
according to the Crimean Tatar national
movement the number of deportees is
twice as high
according to various estimates between
20 and 46 percent of all deported
Crimean tatars died from starvation
exhaustion or illnesses during the first
three years after deportation
Soviet authorities did not stop there in
1944 They carried out another Mass
ethnic cleansing and deported bulgarians
Armenians and Greeks from Crimea less
than two months later the Soviet regime
allowed 51 000 people from other regions
to relocate to Crimea mostly Russians
they were offered the empty houses of
the displaced Crimean tatars to live in
Joseph Stalin was so determined to
eradicate any trace of crimea's
indigenous people that he banned the use
of the ethnonym Crimean tatars
for over 40 years any mention of Crimean
tatars in Soviet censuses was prohibited
the ban on their return to the peninsula
remained in effect until November 1989.
today Ukraine and the Baltic countries
recognized the 1944 deportation of
Crimean tatars as an act of genocide
in the 1990s many tatars began to return
on mass to the peninsula
Crimea is Ukraine firstly we feel free
here it's the most important thing
you breathe differently here you know
in 2014 after Russia annexed Crimea many
of them had to leave their Homeland once
again
the Russian authorities officially
declared the medleys of the Crimean
pathar people to be an extremist
organization just as they did in 1944 in
2014 Russians started to move into
Crimea once again
these actions of the Soviet Union and
its successor Russia stemmed from their
deliberate policy of forced assimilation
of indigenous peoples
this is how a country infected with
Imperial aspirations tries to distort
history and appropriate the things it
never owned
our objective is to participate in
spiritual and religious Pursuits
were forced to leave their Homeland
foreign
[Music]
ukrainians still suffer from
deportations the processes of forced
removal restarted in 2014.
when Russia occupied Crimea and invaded
eastern Ukraine after the full-scale
invasion the deportations of ukrainians
reached a new level
millions of ukrainians ended up outside
of Ukrainian territory against their
will
Edward was inside when his apartment was
shelled he was injured and evacuated
at a checkpoint he asked to go to
Western Ukraine
I told the woman that I wanted to go to
zapure but she answered that there was
no zap parija anymore a Russian military
man was standing nearby who said that
Kiev had already surrendered
one of the motives behind this Russian
crime is their demographic crisis the
fact is the share of ethnic Russians in
the overall population of the country is
declining sharply that's why the Russian
authorities want to increase their
numbers at the expense of ethnic slabs
special attention is paid to the
deportation of Ukrainian children the
occupiers Deport children from the
temporarily occupied territories of
Ukraine including those who were orphans
before this full-scale war or who lost
their parents as a result of it even
children with living parents are taken
away by the Russians as if on holiday
these children are then subjected to
ideological indoctrination and are not
always returned home afterwards other
children are taken from their Ukrainian
families in filtration camps and are
given to Russian families for adoption
the bombing was very intensive
Russian troops entered and we were
evacuated they took me away by car and
the children were taken away by bus
and it was unclear where they were going
of course it was not
[Music]
at first they said that the children
were just going on holiday
but there's no place to go on holiday
here
no
at that time they were all adopted in
Moscow
what was this
not knowing where my children were
Russian authorities do everything they
can to appropriate Ukrainian children in
May 2022 Vladimir Putin signed a decree
that simplified the procedure for
Ukrainian children to receive Russian
citizenship prior to that it was
forbidden in Russia to adopt foreign
children this is how Russia imitates the
legality of adoption for kidnapped
children that make their return to
Ukraine much more complicated
do you know that you are no longer
Ukrainian you are Russian now do you
know that mariopal is now Russian not
Ukraine yes I said it is occupied but
that doesn't make me Russian
I was born in Marie Ukraine so I'm
Ukrainian
according to this new procedure
potential adoptive parents have to
undergo special training where they will
be taught nuances of ideological
education for Ukrainian children among
other things
after adoption the new parents are
required to change the full name of the
adopted Ukrainian child
Russian authorities openly promote this
alleged salvation of children
a prominent example Maria levova bilova
children rights commissioner for the
president of the Russian Federation and
the head of the initiative into the
hands of children
in the Autumn of 2022 she herself
illegally adopted a child kidnapped from
mariopal such actions by Russia violate
the Geneva Convention on the protection
of civilians during wartime
the Russian Orthodox Church is also
engaged in the ideological re-education
of deported Ukrainian children
it promotes the myth about the Russian
World and United Orthodox Slavic Nation
practically every region of Russia where
ukrainians are brought has its own
diocese which takes care of the issues
of alleged evacuees deported ukrainians
are stationed in monasteries and other
facilities belonging to the church where
they are subjected to educational and
enlightening talks
according to information obtained by the
hacker groups Anonymous and DDO Secrets
at the beginning of the full-scale war
the Russian Orthodox Church was making
preparations for deportation long before
the actual invasion
the Russian Ministry of Defense along
with some other Russian sources reports
that during the first 11 months of the
full-scale war more than 733 000
children from the temporarily occupied
territories of Ukraine were allegedly
saved they are resettled across the
entirety of Russia including sakolan
Island
1090 orphans from various children's
institutions came to us so what is your
opinion our citizens have of course big
hearts and they are already lining up to
take the children in if you allow I will
continue this work we have already
created a register of those who have
documents and some perhaps could be
temporarily placed some with Russian
citizenship could already be
accommodated why only with Russian with
any citizenship there are just some
bureaucracy which needs to be eliminated
then
you say which one we will liquidate it
these are extraordinary circumstances
and we should think not about some red
hate but about the interests of children
the figures published by Maria yavova
belova from time to time do not match
the official reports of her own into the
hands of children organization
this indicates deliberate concealment of
The Facts of deportation
the reported information of deported
Ukrainian children is growing rapidly
but unfortunately very few of them are
supported by any official data Ukrainian
human rights Defenders and Law
Enforcement Officers check any
information about deported people the
specialized portal children of War
reports that as of today the names of
approximately fifteen thousand of the
deported children have been confirmed on
the 17th of March 2023 the international
criminal court seated in The Hague
issued arrest warrants against Vladimir
Putin and Maria levova Bulova for their
alleged responsibility in the war crime
of unlawful deportation of children from
occupied areas of Ukraine to Russia
while masking the deportations of
ukrainians behind other words such as
evacuation salvation and holiday Russia
carries out its deliberate policy of
extermination of Ukrainian people
this terrorist state must be stopped
because it has no intention of halting
its crimes against humanity